[Music]
welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast i'm your
host hisham azuz and this week i sat
down with the amazing tara jackson from
a company called venetrix
what we discuss in this episode and what
we try to achieve with this episode is
talking about how building a successful
career in 180 recruitment delivery
recruitment whatever you want to call it
is nothing to be ashamed of and why it
should not be seen as a career path that
isn't as good as a 360 recruitment
consultant um and those things so we
really dug deep into what do you have to
do to be a absolute killer delivery
consultant tara's now progressed all the
way to a manager so she's also managing
people but we really got into how she
consistently generates candidates
through referrals by building her brand
on linkedin how she's gone about
managing a team now and passing on all
the things that have worked for her and
how she's also really reignited her
career as a delivery consultant and how
that then showed up in that performance
where in her most recent year she built
400 grand as a delivery consultant
enjoy the episode
tara welcome to the podcast thank you
thank you for having me been looking
forward to this obviously we are
hopefully for everyone listening on this
episode we are on a mission
to educate inspire a career
in delivery yeah 180 whatever you want
to call it so where i want to start
obviously you've been in recruitment for
four years had your recent fourth year
anniversary
and you've really carved out yourself a
successful career in being in a 180 role
so we're going to really get into the
sort of weeds of like how you've done
that advice maybe you give yourself
early on and these types of things so
where i'd really like to start and get
your thoughts on from the sort of
journey you've been on so far what what
do you believe are the maybe common
characteristics or traits that you would
maybe see and have seen in the top
performers around you and and what makes
up a successful consultant in today's
market do you think yeah definitely so
i think one of the main things
that i think you have to be is brave i
think it is a really really difficult
job and i think it's the main reason why
people leave recruitment is because like
they can't do it but i think everyone
can do it if you're brave enough to try
lots of different things
and the other main thing is being
authentic so
i remember when i graduated there were
thousands and thousands of recruiters on
linkedin messaging me just posting
loads of bulk texts on linkedin and i
was like oh my god i don't want to speak
to any of these people they're so scary
like that word recruiter gave me the
fear so it's something that we've really
tried to do at venetrix and i've very
much built a personal brand around doing
those videos that
i think
you gain that trust from people that
they realize oh she's a normal person
she has a normal life um
that people buy into you
um the other thing is
i think it comes down to the company and
i think if the company aren't helping
people to understand like why you're
doing that job every single day like
what is the vision what is the mission
and where do you want the company to get
to it's very hard for people to be
successful because they don't know where
they're getting why
whereas if you've got someone that wants
to like try
different ways of doing the job every
single day someone that wants to do
things differently plus they know what
the vision is of the company that's
going to be a recipe for success yeah
brave i love that word brave i think
you're the first person to say that i
think that's a great way to put it you
100 have to be brave i love that your
authenticity i really like that how how
did you we had someone in here last time
a guy called and
and one of the sort of uh things that he
got in hindsight was he put it in a
really really cool way he was just like
in the when things really kicked on for
him was when he really brought himself
to work
but leading up to that he tried to put
on this sort of professional
facade of light sometimes you have to
you feel like you have to wear this
professional mask don't you did you did
you it's like did you experience that
like tara in the venetrix environment or
in the work environment was a bit
different
i don't know i think what's difficult is
in recruitment you have to have that
control over the candidate so it's um
when we hire people it's trying to tell
them of like you've got to get that
control but also they've got to buy into
you as a person so
it's i think that's the really difficult
part because if i got on a call with
every single candidate and was like oh i
did this on the weekend and did that
you still need them to respect you sure
um so definitely were times where i
probably was super corporate tyron that
was probably a lot pre-covered whereas
then i think when we went through covid
everyone was doing zoom calls in their
bedroom we had i had a puppy that was
like running into um where i was working
like every single day on every call so i
think people then realize that you are a
real person and you can still have that
control but
they can know a bit more about you you
yeah also maybe grew into it then or
like okay that's interesting but that
was two years in so
i'd done recruitment for two years and
then i think
we'll speak about it later but covered
was a very pivotal part for me of like
totally changing my career and starting
to be
really successful um so i think that's
hand in hand good balance yeah so let's
start with then the beginning uh i think
would be a good place to start let's
maybe sort of um compile into the first
two years as you said and then the last
two years so
who who was tara before recruitment then
where were you at oh god
so i just graduated from university okay
i hadn't even got my results yet did you
get a degree at venetrix um so i
actually started doing international
hospitality management wow okay i had no
idea what i wanted to do i wasn't a high
achiever at anything really um
but i was always winning awards for
trying hard so i was never the best at
sport or the best academically but it
was i was always winning the endeavor
prize wow um
and so worked at loads of like golf
clubs and bars and thought oh i'm going
to be a like organised weddings and it's
going to be so glamorous went to
university and had to spend the first
semester in a kitchen learning how
kitchens work and i was like i can't do
this this isn't for me so i then had a
couple of friends that did business and
marketing thought right try that give it
a go so started doing that and did a
placement year in marketing okay saw the
sales team and i was like that's what i
want to be doing and so
started when i graduated looking for
lots of roles
again didn't really have any direction
on what it was and i met my ceo my
director sophie and elaine and i was
like that's what i do i was like that is
100 i didn't care about recruitment
working with them doing anything and i
was like that is who i want to work with
so let it be good just just before we go
on i think obviously we're getting into
graduate graduation season now and i've
got a few things planned but it'd be
good just to get your thoughts on
because you obviously you you work with
the entry level market right so i guess
it'd be good just get your take on now
like obviously that was uh four or so
years ago in hindsight what what is your
advice to like young people graduating
of like getting a feel or understanding
of what is it they want to do because it
can be so whenever i speak to people
they've got the pressure on themselves
of life just got this degree
i don't want to be a failure like i've
got all this debt now i need to make the
most of it then got the pressure of
their parents like is tara and my child
going to do something that yeah we want
them to do there's so many different
things and you're like i have no [ __ ]
clue what i want to do yeah what should
i watch those people because i'm sure
you dish this out quite a bit yeah
100 i think you can't be afraid to fail
i mean i never
from day one at venetrix to probably
that two year mark i probably every week
went through a part where i was like oh
my gosh i can't do this anymore it's
really difficult
my best advice is always to break it up
into not job titles not sectors think
about what do you want in a job do you
want a job that's going to require you
to be picking up the phone to people do
you want to be speaking to people do you
want to be working towards targets do
you want to be in an office like what's
that
environment that you want because
no one knows from doing a degree if they
want to work in recruitment if they want
to work in marketing
you don't know until you're in that
commercial environment so i always say
people will accept a job at the company
where they feel really inspired by the
leader
and that is the person that's the most
important choose throughout elaine's
still the most important person to be in
the working world um and we're four
years in so it's that person that you're
going to learn from
you're going to learn everything from so
if you don't buy into them if you're not
inspired by them you're not going to
want to do the job yeah i like that i
know i like what you said around like
really dial in and focus on the types of
things that you feel you would enjoy and
want to be doing in a role rather than
what the job title is the sector and
those things yeah job titles mean
absolutely nothing like even for
recruitment you've got delivery
consultant talent executive
junior recruitment consultant everyone
calls themselves a different thing and
like that doesn't matter i think you
have to really think about who you're
going to be working with on a day-to-day
basis and that journey and mission that
the company's going on because that's
what's going to inspire you on a
day-to-day basis yeah and then i think i
really like what you said around like
yeah don't be afraid to fail as well
because i think that's i didn't go to
university so i didn't have those
pressures but whenever i've spoken to
people that graduated and up in
recruitment or whatever some of the
things i always pick up on is they just
have they're very locked in on landing
the perfect role and the perfect
position out of unity they it has to be
the perfect one these types of things
but i don't know my perspective on it
and i don't know if you would agree is
like
yeah start focusing on perfect and focus
on like you said being in an environment
where you think you'd enjoy and it's all
about experimentation like you will
still be able to get a job if you go
into a job and you don't you don't end
up enjoying it and you're there for
three months and then you go into
another thing like i don't know i just
feel like yeah like it's all about
experimentation and tasting and
understanding what you want and what you
like 100 and a question that i get asked
a lot is if someone's been in a job for
three months they say oh my gosh does
this look really bad that i'm leaving
should i stick it out for a year no no
yeah why why do a job that you know
you're going to leave and you don't see
that progressing in a company and even
if i was interviewing someone i'd much
rather someone said i've done this job
for three months this is what i've
learned this is now what i know i do and
don't want to do so this is what i'm
looking for moving forward i think
no one knows what they want to do yeah
rather than like i have to stay here to
make my cv look good yeah and like no i
don't even read the cvs i'd much rather
like jump on zoom speak to someone on
the phone because why are we judging
junior people based on an a4 piece of
paper when you're hiring someone based
on potential yeah i love that so let's
break down this first two years then
what what were some of the biggest
challenges then for you like what why do
you think in hindsight now
why do you what were some of the things
that you felt were holding you back
let's let's start there so i think i was
going through a big transition i was
what 21
graduated from university moving to
london suddenly you're earning a salary
you're earning commission it's like oh
my god i can go out all the time so it
was just that crazy whirlwind
of
life
i think was having a massive impact
i think i found again not being a high
achiever at gcse's a levels uni i was
just normal
just coaster
i
it was really really difficult and i'm
someone that i do like to do
well um especially in that target-based
environment i
like to have good numbers on the board
and be being feeling successful
so when your whole world comes crashing
down and every single candidate cancels
interviews and candidates are leaving
jobs you are literally like i can't do
it anymore like there were days where i
would just like sob at my desk um would
have to be taken to starbucks to like
calm down
and one thing that i think is really
important is remembering the bigger
picture that and i think that's what i
couldn't do because
i was quite
i think maybe quite naive to what i
could achieve within the business
um so i think just like when one day
went wrong i was oh my god i can't do it
anymore like this is all going wrong
whereas now i have a bad week have a bad
month i'm like okay well what's the next
six months gonna look like what's the
next year gonna look like yeah but i
think it's uh
i think recruitment's a really hard job
to do when you're that young yeah i mean
you're dealing with so many people and
so many you're dealing with other
people's emotions your emotions and
trying to do a job where it's hard to
control people they do whatever the hell
they want
i think you do
grow into it as you mature for sure so
let's talk about you mentioned going to
starbucks there
what what's like the ritual now for tara
if like [ __ ] goes wrong like
candidate accepts a job somewhere else
candidate goes through even though you
just put all this effort into them
you've got them a job offer they're
going to sign a contract
don't turn up on the day
like we all know how difficult this is
and your world is all about candidate
relationships for candidate management
so
what's the ritual for you this will be
helpful for people it's a ritual for you
to get over those days where you have
those setbacks it's not a life or death
situation that's the question you say i
literally say that to myself i said to
myself outside of work now as well of it
just
doesn't matter and i think it comes back
to a company helping people to
understand the long-term vision because
if i cried about every single candidate
that dropped out of an interview didn't
turn up to an interview
you can't move forward so
just thinking right why would i why am i
going to waste my time
on that person that
doesn't want to accept that job like why
didn't i go and cold call 10 other
people that i've never spoken to before
so just remembering like nothing is
going to go wrong no one is going to die
in the situation
it's fine
and i think that's the hardest thing
again when you first start like it's
fine it's just a job it doesn't it does
matter because you want to hit your
target but like it doesn't matter like
no one's ever going to be angry at you
um and then being able to learn like
right what could i do differently nice
yeah that's a good question to ask so we
use we record all of our zoom calls all
of our phone calls then
i'll go back not always on the same day
but maybe a couple days later and be
like right okay i'm going to re-watch
that zoom call like what did i miss
that they said to me of like that i
should have
realized i realized yeah and then do you
do anything like a lot of people i've
sat down with they like go out and go
for a walk or anything like that yeah so
sometimes if i go for a walk i find it
if i'm really angry then i'll be like
right going for a walk over coffee even
got a glass of wine i'll be like i've
just got to get over it but i think i
really have got to that stage where like
it doesn't affect me
when we hire junior people into the
business it's that
your heart feels for them when they
are so excited about a candidate then
they just get ghosted and it's just
trying to help people understand like it
is gonna be fine like it's gonna happen
to you
loads um i actually wrote a linkedin
post about a candidate that ghosted me
once and just said think it's so sad
that you can invest so much time in
someone and then they just vanish off
the face of the earth and the candidate
read it and they message me and they
were like i am so sorry like i didn't
realize how it come across so also just
call the candidate out um like
i've said to them before like look
totally understand you don't want the
job but like why are you treating me
like a piece of [ __ ] like it's not it's
not fella i'm just doing my job trying
to help you
have the respect yeah i think obviously
there's there's so many different
reasons isn't there but i feel like it's
just quite short side isn't it
especially when you're doing entry-level
talent like that i don't know that you
could end up being helpful along the way
at some point exactly and i always think
that is the best way to end a
relationship with a candidate is saying
like oh
like i couldn't help you but
let's keep in touch and i've had
candidates that i haven't helped and
they've sent me hundreds or hundreds
loads of referrals
so back to that word brave i want to
pick up on something you just said like
i think it's brave to be able to look
yourself in the mirror and go what could
have done better and watch your video
back listen to the thing because that
that can be difficult
so like how how did you unlock the
willingness for you to do that because
i'm sure that can be quite hard just to
like lean into that straight away
because i don't think anyone likes i
don't know that's hard for a lot of
people i feel like to be willing to go
look at literally watch what i did and
go i could have done that better like
did you always were you always willing
to do that or was there anything that
helped you understand why that's so
important or why that's the right
mindset yeah no i used to absolutely
hate it so when everyone when anyone
first starts we have to do call
listening okay and it was my worst
nightmare and when my manager was like
right now listen to this call on the way
home like you're gonna listen to it as
well i'm gonna go through it i dreaded
it it was my worst nightmare having to
sit down and like go through all of it
all of that i remember one time someone
was like you let you sound like a
screaming child like you're so
high-pitched
i was like i just hate this
um
so it's really it's difficult i think it
comes from
like wanting to be better and
we use this platform called gemini where
everything's recorded i can watch
anyone's calls anyone can watch mine and
we've now created a culture where we
want everyone to
have feedback but i think if i didn't
watch my own calls
how am i ever going to get how is anyone
ever going to get better um i do like
cringe at some of the things i think why
did i say that but i mean you learn one
thing from watching 30 seconds of it and
then you move forward um i don't always
sometimes what i'll do is i'll put my
laptop like if i'm cooking like on the
side play it and i won't even be sitting
there making notes but i'll just be
listening to the conversation whilst
doing something else rather than having
my music blurring just to try and do it
in that way of listening to like
snippets that i've said that i like or
things that i don't like no i love that
i think i think more of it should happen
in recruitment i don't think as much of
it does it i know obviously because of
the word that you recruit and it's like
so normal that that's like the way that
people upscale and get better but yeah i
think like you just said i think the
mindset has to just be like i'm doing
this because i'm trying to like improve
my performance by one percent it takes
one thing rather than this isn't an
exercise for me to just get sort of
taken down or getting negative stuff
from it this is just about improving
yeah i do think it massively comes from
the culture though and i will go on to
it with 180 but
where the majority of our team do do 180
recruitment i think it makes us a lot
more collaborative because we have to
have that relationship with the team
that are doing bd and working together
so there is that very open
feedback circle where i'll everyone will
post a um
a link in the slack channel have been
like oh listen to this or someone did
this really well that it's creating that
culture where people aren't scared to
have their calls listened to or aren't
scared about what they're saying and
that's probably i had that fear of
failing which was why i used to hate
listening to my calls whereas now
like if someone listened to it and they
were like why did you say that i should
be like oh no let's change it whereas at
the beginning it's that fear of
failing whereas now i feel like i'm so
much more brave with recruitment i'll
try something if it goes wrong doesn't
matter no one's died i've tried it yeah
i love that okay cool so let's talk
about let's talk about performance then
what what did what was the best year for
you in those first two years then and
then we can talk about
how uh you unlocked your potential mate
the next two years after it probably
wasn't even from a billing
perspective probably the
happy well the most exciting time for me
was when we started doing
linkedin videos because i wasn't doing
very well at all couldn't find any
candidates was like what am i going to
do and i literally posted a selfie on
linkedin with someone that's big in the
software industry and it just got like
200 likes and i was like oh my god this
is so good okay let me let me backtrack
wait sorry so i i definitely go into so
like no no no it's fine i guess what i
wanted to find out was in
in the first two years and then we'll
select in the first two years what was
your best year like billions was oh
probably like 150 okay yeah because i
then want to say and then obviously then
the last year you just did this
yes 150 right yeah okay cool so actually
wait it says can i change it yeah let's
do it let's say 100.
does that sound more impressive
can't remember all right okay cool so
yeah first two years like better you had
billions of was like around 100 right as
you said okay so i guess the first thing
i wanted to do before we go into this
the last two years is talk to me about a
day in the life of a delivery person
like because typically like i was in a
360
environment so you can easily break up
your day be the candidate but like you
are like yeah just talk to us about what
does a delivery professional like what
does that typically game look like and
make up and then we'll just break it
down yeah now now okay so
a massive thing for us is personal brand
so we want everyone in the company to do
about four videos on linkedin a week so
my day always will start with a linkedin
video because i think to be successful
you have to be consistent so linkedin
video out by 8 30. so once i've done
that i will then start my day with
going through anything that like is
urgent so like any cvs that have come
into my inbox i need feedback that needs
to be actioned or anything like that so
i usually always break like leave myself
8 30 till 9 to do all of that
um then depending on
how we work is we basically do a
qualification call with a candidate if
we think they could be a good fit we'll
then get them on a zoom interview so
i'll then
start doing a call out or i'll go
straight on to zoom interviews perfect
day is where you speak to like three
perfect zoom interviews they're really
bought into the process you think they
could be a really good fit and then we
invite people to virtual assessments
um
stringed in with a couple of job offers
is a perfect day okay nice all right so
a real mixture of basically
building your candidate pipeline trying
to generate referrals speak to people
obviously for you guys with your
business model you have assessment
centers
and then are you and then also are you
actively involved in taking the offer to
the candidates if they get to that or
what's the part of that as well so
that's split so in terms of the the
in terms of the resources job at
venetrix so it's to find the candidate
invite them to a virtual assessment and
then mentor them through that whole
interview process so that can even be we
still pitch them the jobs it's just got
an account manager that would then deal
liaise directly with the client
um so we manage them through that whole
process we take feedback after every
single interview they've been to and get
feedback from the clients the account
manager actually takes the feedback from
the candidate and the client just to
streamline that process
then when it gets to the job offers the
usually the account manager will do it
but it's something that we
train everyone to do and give people the
opportunity to do because it is one of
my favorite things so if i was like can
i do a job offer yes like it's fine it's
just when the
if the account manager is doing it
they've just got a bit more control over
if the candidate's trying to like
negotiate the salary and things like
that rather than it being like
us trying to go back and then me passing
a message to someone else
um but we do something called a lunch
and learn where we cover different
topics so the next one we've got coming
up is around taking feedback and job
offers so even though people are still
only on that candidate side we're still
giving them full exposure to
the whole process
and again with all of those calls being
recorded everyone can go and listen to
them of how it's done hey everyone a
real quick one from me this podcast
would not be possible without our
amazing podcast partners vincerie and
sauce breaker because you listen to this
podcast you're able to get your hands on
exclusive savings on both of these
award-winning products if you're all a
growing recruitment business you have to
check out vincerie who are an all-in-one
operating system for your growing
recruitment business with sourcebreaker
if you want to make sure that all of
your recruiters have the best tools on
the market to stand out and beat their
competition then you have to check out
sourcebreaker use the link in the show
notes in the comments below and you'll
be able to get yourself exclusive
savings on these amazing products
so let's obviously i really want to i
really want to get into like the
principles from everything that you've
learned so far of like what can um help
people listen to this on a delivery
environment to be really successful but
i want to start as you talking about
earlier before i cut you off was um like
what what do you think are some of the
key things that changed in the last two
you said obviously from kovid it's been
yeah there's been like a real growth for
you yeah so talk to me about some of the
things that you think looking back now
so you had your four-year anniversary
recently in the last two years what some
of the things that maybe you change or
things that happen that you think had a
real impact on where you've ended up
yeah so pre-covered venetrix was a very
different recruitment company to where
it is now
and
i think
the main thing for me of when i really
started to see success was that i felt
really really empowered in the role and
it wasn't that i wasn't being like no
one have everyone had my back before but
when we went into covert there were only
three of us working and i was one of
those three and it was more like oh [ __ ]
like this is gonna be really really
difficult and
for me that was very much the turning
point of like right i need to do this
now
um so i think it's when i speak to
people that are doing 180 recruitment
and i'm like oh like why don't you like
it they're just like oh well just
finding candidates aren't i so
i think what we try what we do at
venatrix is empower everyone in the
company to like not just do their job do
podcasts do webinars like what can you
do outside of just finding candidates so
for me it was then seeing this bigger
picture of
i think pre-covered i was just like
doing the job for a job whereas i
very much when we got to coven it was
like right this is our vision this is
the mission
even though it was just to get through
whereas now it's like every morning well
every monday morning it's like right
this is where we're at revenue wise this
is where we're at in terms of compared
to last year that everyone's now got
this exposure to the vision of the
company which i may think make it
makes everyone feel like yeah you don't
yeah you're not just like i'm just doing
candidates all day yeah you're taking a
step back and being like wow i have a
really important part to play in the
business and the vision and creating and
that's where there was the turning point
that i i
understood why i was doing the job
whereas pre covered i was just doing the
job to get some money to go to the pub
on a friday whereas now i'm like right
i'm doing this job because i want us to
get to this point but i always also like
actually want to help candidates
get the right job for them and be really
successful i love that
anything specific so you mentioned that
obviously you're saying that personal
branding ended up being big yeah so did
you not post that much but in the first
two years then i just posted chunks of
text really yeah
wow
i don't think anyone did photos or
yeah like loads of videos whereas now i
would probably 90 of my placements or
referrals or from linkedin really i
don't i so why did i end up being a
pivotal moment for you beyond the light
being part of the bigger picture because
you said that in clover you posted a
picture or whatever and then you're like
oh my god like this is a way that i can
this is a way of me doing recruitment
which i didn't realize i could do before
so i think it's the stigma around
recruitment so when i was on the job
search at uni i was chucked into
interviews left right and center like
people just ring me back you didn't
interview in five minutes like yeah of
course i can because i'm a naive little
graduate yeah um
whereas so i hated recruiters i was like
i never want to speak to a recruiter
again like they are evil like they just
want to get a tick box of getting me to
that interview
whereas when we started doing the videos
i think it helped people to understand
like oh she is just a normal person
where is this like not this scary
recruiter behind a screen just posting
loads of texts and i think when
people are looking for a job especially
entry-level people it's a really
nerve-wracking time like you said when
you're coming out of university what do
i want to do that sometimes i have a
half an hour zoom call with someone it's
got nothing about me helping them get a
job it's them asking me questions of
like what do the jobs do how do i
commission like what does this do and
me giving my time to people like that
and people feeling like they can
approach me i find really rewarding and
i think is why
i've become successful that
i'm someone that people can talk to when
they don't know they don't have any
direction they don't know where they're
going and i just yeah so and sharing
things online just enabled you to really
yeah showcase that people bought into
that yeah i think that had a real
positive impact yeah and i think when
when you're especially graduates they
don't know what they want to do there
are thousands of
job posts online that if they can
actually just be really open and i jump
on a zoom and someone's like i don't
know what i want to do like can you help
me
they've seen like my personality from
that video which is why they've reached
out to me so i think that's really
helped on being able to stand out okay
cool so talk to me about then on this
journey you've been on so far what would
you say are
like the principles of being like a [ __ ]
hot delivery consultant like what what
do you think what have you come to
consistently think about i need to get
one percent better this every day like
what are the fundamentals and principles
to be in the successful delivery
consultant that people have to work
towards getting right yep so the main
thing is consistency okay you have to do
every single process
the whole time so it's something we were
talking about this week because some
weeks i'll get 10 referrals and some
weeks i'll get none
it's all like fun and games when these
referrals are coming in and i mean
the candidates are more bought into the
process because their friends got a job
from it um but the moment that i've
taken my foot off the gas and thought oh
it's fine i don't need to make sure i'll
come closer today i don't need to go
through any applications i don't need to
do another like do a linkedin recruiter
project
that's when
trouble starts to be consistent with the
things that the activities that you're
not going to do yes so something that um
me and a girl called saskia on the team
did a couple of weeks ago was we broke
our whole week up into hours
right how many hours do all the
one-to-ones take how many hours do the
team meetings um take how many hours
does it take to fill my linkedin content
how many hours do i need for resourcing
and we broke up that way to then have
more of a tick list and to block out our
time
of
when you've got 20 minutes spare in
between a call rather than like i'm just
going to go for a walk around the
kitchen get my washing out be like right
okay well i can do that job i can film
two linkedin videos in that time
so
it's the consistency factor and doing
everything every single day
that you know works
rather than taking your foot off the gas
but then i think also reflecting on that
that you can't just your voicemails
can't be the same every single time
because
then reflecting on what's working
reflect on what's working not work
what's not working and change it like
you have to try new things
i love that so like a couple of weeks
ago i started
sending candidates videos on linkedin
we've started doing voice notes on
linkedin
have i seen much success with it no i
think people think it's a little bit
weird
but doing it as an experiment like you
have to try different things things will
work for three months
and then no one replied to an email like
so mixing it up what's been the most
consistent way of you generating
candidates do you think like
activity-wise
linkedin really a hundred percent
linkedin videos and she's a personal
brand yeah i think when people enjoy the
process and we invest a lot of time into
these candidates that when they
get a job they are really grateful
especially when they're making that
really important decision they're so
grateful to us that
when they're happy with the process they
do want to send their friends to you
they've just got a really cool job
they're at the pub saying oh i've done
this they are going to send you
referrals so
we were talking about it um on one of
the recruitment mentors sessions of if
you've given someone that good
experience
they are going to want to refer their
friends to you because it's built that
element of trust yeah it's so
interesting right so being really honest
with you i know obviously a couple of
entry-level focus recruitment companies
and whenever i speak to them it seems
like they're very reliant on job boards
and like haven't quite cracked linkedin
or like i don't know like so you
obviously clearly clearly it's working
for you guys but are you consistently
finding them that more and more people
coming through and graduates are on
linkedin more earlier are using it
because it has dramatically changed yeah
it's i think a lot more people are on
linkedin like i don't understand people
that
aren't yeah i think it's really weird as
a graduate too not really weird i think
it's strange to not
have a profile
um
i think it's a thing that is really bad
at universities it's something that they
don't promote it you are pushed on the
like you've got to go on a graduate
scheme this is all you can do so the
majority of people that i speak to again
it's that friendly face of like oh my
gosh there's an entry-level role there
that i don't like there aren't um
you they are going to be able to do it
um
i think it's become i've done it for
four years i know people in the team
that do use the job boards a lot um
but for me i think i've just had that
i've got that reputation in the market
now where someone thinks right i wanna i
want an sdr role i've got a friend that
wants one oh tara doesn't sdr roles okay
um
but i think it's what we do at venetrix
we are like laser sharp focused on only
recruiting sdrs for the software
industry so
if anyone we've got that reputation of
you want an sdr go to venetrix you want
to be an sdr go to venetrix whereas when
the net is cast so wide maybe it's
harder to have that reputation well i
guess anyone listening if you're on a
delivery i mean anyone for me i've been
advocating this for a while but you have
to invest in your personal brand i mean
that's just clear evident how much of an
impact that has had in your role and how
much it's helped you
um
i guess when it comes to obviously
you've recently gone on a management
journey yes what's that been like tough
i've so it got to the point where
um there was a role advertised for a
team leader role i was very anti
managing a team i was like lone wolf
just wanted to do my own thing
and
i again it was in covet and i was like i
feel so passionate about growing the
team internally
that's what i want to do
um managing people is really really
tough because they throw things at you
that you just don't even expect or
know how to handle um
it it's difficult but i love it i think
there is nothing more rewarding what's
my surprise with you
oh
gosh what's most surprised me
i think i think how difficult the job is
i think everyone thinks oh it's so easy
to be a manager like you just manage
people like it's it's the one-to-ones
it's the questions it's the not getting
worked up when they're worked up or like
if they not argue with you but say
something that like you don't agree with
how to
like think about it and then go back
with an answer so like something that i
learned very early on was like never go
into a call not knowing what the call's
about so someone's like oh can i speak
to you what's it about so that you can
prepare yourself
for whatever it's going to be not
blindsided and i think i have a very
quick temper
in the workplace um but i have a very
quick temper um
and that challenge learning to channel
that in the world yeah so yeah and
that's been one thing that's been really
important for me um like my ceo is
amazing like i can just on the event to
her about something that's like gone
wrong but for me it's really been like
how to challenge that so i write a lot
of like my thoughts down of things that
have annoyed me and then like just throw
the paper away and then it's like out of
my head and i'm like right i feel so
much better now interesting so advice
for people on that journey right that
might be just trying to travel
i think
what you've got to remember is that if
you hire the right person they are just
trying to do
their job and going through
the emotions of it so one thing i always
just think of like oh my god what was i
like in that position and like house
they're not at that brave stage yet
they're still at the scared stage so
sometimes the way that they're reacting
it's not against you it's just you're
there sounding bored so you are the
first person that they're gonna get
pissed off with get annoyed with so
dealing with that that it again it's not
personal
you are just the person that is going to
get the brunt of that sometimes yeah i
love that so massive i'd be keen to get
your thoughts on this like obviously
clearly you've said you're such a
collaborative environment
um you elaine and sophie worked really
hard on this but like obviously a
massive part of your role in people and
delivery is reliant on like the
other people in the business right
so what what's what are like the
fundamentals to like i guess getting to
working towards having a really good
relationship with your account
management team whatever you want to
call it to really make sure that you the
delivery professional is on the same
page as them and like you're working
together rather than the account manager
going [ __ ] say tara like this isn't
right you didn't listen to me what have
been yeah how have you really made sure
that that relationship is really good
because it has to be in order for you to
hit your goals and overachieve and those
things yeah definitely that's a great
question and actually our most
successful business development account
manager is sophie who's based in france
so she's not even in the london office
with the team so that
communication is so important so
um we didn't used to have slack we used
to use whatsapp and something that we
had to stop quite quickly was the
whatsapp conversations because things
are read in such a different tone of
voice than what they're meant to be so
i've worked with sophie for four years
i can send a message and she knows
probably how i'm saying it whereas
someone that's only been in the company
for two months if someone said something
someone might take it the wrong way so
we got slack where then like everything
is now done on slack so it's like this
is work don't mix the personal stuff
yeah with it so we've got a different
set of different channels different
channels we do a team meeting every
morning at 8 30. everyone is on that
zoom call and we also do one at 5 p.m so
everyone we go through every single job
that we're recruiting for every single
candidate that we've got live so that if
there are any matches or anything like
that people
have had that conversation
um and we speak all day every day on
slack so everything is answered
everything is done i think
it's
with the delivery thing it's empowering
those people to feel like
they're not just a delivery consultant
that they are actually like oh [ __ ] i'm
actually generating loads of revenue to
make this company successful and i think
that's where you're going to get the
people that take the job more seriously
rather than someone being like aren't
you finding some candidates like i'm
bored of this and i think it comes from
companies not empowering people whereas
like we cannot i can still go and send
an email to a client and arrange an
interview and do that i don't need
permission from it's not that i can't do
it but we have to split the business to
get the best
for the business so our biggest
challenge is finding enough high-caliber
candidates we've got enough clients
we've got enough inbound leads we've got
that reputation but the hardest thing is
is the candidates
what would your advice be for someone
that's listened to right now in a
delivery role and they've got they're
working with a difficult account manager
and like i don't know i feel like
because i'm sure you've like have you
like how have you gone about maybe
there'll be moments where you and so if
you haven't quite seen eye to eye or
like you've had to like it must be hard
to then give feedback or like work out i
don't know i'm sure there's ways that on
a consistent basis you have to
consistently work out how to give
feedback
to someone that's because that can be
hard yeah and it's difficult me and
sophia now literally best friends yeah
and
there are still days sometimes at work
crime like oh my god and she's probably
like what the hell are you doing tara
and like it does happen i think the best
thing that we've learned to do again
write it all down
get on a zoom call with them or if
they're in person have that conversation
because all you do is rile yourself up
and get more and more annoyed at
something i feel like in that role you
can you could end up pointing the finger
couldn't you because i've got these
[ __ ] great people and then and then
and you pass that over then it hasn't
worked out for a reason so yeah i feel
like that's so important yeah and it's
like
again it comes from having that vision
within the company whereas like if a
client cancels an interview i know
that's not sophie making the decision
like that's just an external factor that
we can't do anything about so again like
not a life or death situation what else
can we do like where else can that
candidate be a good fit and like working
as that collaborative team
to
for everyone to be successful and i
think that's something that the account
managers are really good at is wanting
it's not just like they're the top
billers no one else can be successful
it's like right how can i help that
candidate make another pl that um
consultant in the team be successful no
you're right you've both yeah like it's
you're going to be fighting uphill
battle if the account manager thinks
they're better than you or like their
job's more important and you've both got
to be aligned with like look if we're
both successful and we make this work as
best as it can we both win
that can be lost yeah and i think if one
thing that
people also have to do is if you've got
more experience than someone else on a
team like be nice like help them and
don't mean i would always jump on a call
with someone's candidate that they were
struggling with try and help them with
that and again it's
it's when these recruitment companies
have these hierarchies of like oh we're
the account managers you're the delivery
like we are so different like why are
you making someone feel like that
because ultimately you're all
working in the same company to drive
revenue for that company so why are you
creating that divide to not make people
feel good in their job
does that make sense
yeah i think that is where this why
people leave these 180 recruitment roles
because they don't feel like they're
doing anything to make a difference yeah
100
so what ended up being uh your best year
then last two years come on um
last last year was really good did 400
000. so yes so really happy with that
definitely want to beat it this year so
we're on track at the moment but yeah i
uh you must be so proud of that that is
that definitely isn't a what is it
word on torah for just showing up and
doing okay work and these things like in
the past absolutely smashed it yeah no i
i we did a kick-off yesterday and i
actually said i was like one of my
achievements is that i get to wake up
every day and like actually love my job
and like love everyone that i work with
love the candidates most of them i speak
to
um
and it is so rewarding i think
when you are when you feel empowered in
the job
everything that internal feeling there
is nothing better like the commission's
amazing and the perks and everything but
how you feel
your combo process yeah you can't put a
price on it and i think that is what i
love the most about so yeah i guess that
that's amazing right so i think
showcases the earning capability in the
delivery role which maybe some people
think is limited and there's glass
ceilings i guess the other thing that
maybe some people may have reservations
around or think about it is and i think
you touched on it but it'd be good just
to get your thoughts on it is how have
you approached or how has it not become
like repetitive and like quote unquote
boring because you're just doing the
candidate side like how have you added
variety i guess it might come back to
the experiments that you tried but like
how have you made sure that yeah you're
not it's just like this you've only got
that one element so you're not getting
bored of the things that you're doing
yeah yeah
yeah oh that's a good one i think
if you're getting bored in that delivery
role i'd probably say like you're not
it's either not for you or you're not in
the right company that's making you feel
bored um
we
i think it's the internal satisfaction
like every single candidate i help get a
job it's rewarding so
even though i am doing the same job
every single day it's the same zoom call
that i'm doing
i still feel
really excited doing it and speaking to
different people but i think it's more
also the journey that venatrix is going
on and
that's also exciting so it's not like
just the delivery side of it that i'm
doing it's like oh my gosh we're gonna
if we open an office here next year and
things like that it's that journey that
you're going on with the company as well
yeah because like if everyone does the
same job every single year no yeah
you're right even if you're an
accountant the job's not gonna change
drastically
when you do it but i think it's this
mindset around delivery again like just
not empowering people and think they're
just thinking of finding candidates the
rest of my life yeah for sure yeah it's
not that well i think obviously some of
the things that you guys do well from
what i know and understand about your
business and you touched on it earlier
is like i think i guess what i was
trying to lead to is like some of the
things that you like you don't just you
don't just have one way of finding
people like you're doing your linkedin
videos you're doing all these different
things you're now managing so you've got
the variety in that sense and then i
think also from the stuff that i've seen
from you guys you've then really lent
into like what other ways can we do to
impact the community and people that
we're helping so you've got the the
community that you're involved in or
i've seen sometimes like meet candidates
for drinks so i feel like i guess what i
was trying to teach you up to say was
like no no
it's like obviously
because i think some people think it's
like you said but like there will be
again creative ways if you're in the
right environment to do other things
that bring variety and other ways that
you can do things in your role yeah no
no that definitely is a good point and
we do do a lot in the community we go
and meet all of our clients and meet all
of our candidates
um
which does make the job really enjoyable
when you're seeing like the end goal um
so yeah i know that definitely that's a
good point thanks for that so i guess as
you come to the end here then like why
why should more people
consider and be excited by
a career in a 180 role like yeah why
should people consider that and what's
exciting about it so
i think it goes back to when i first
started if someone had made me do 360
recruitment i would have been out of
recruitment in six months i think
because i think when you are so
especially for entry level people
starting which is where most people
start their recruitment career
i think it is really difficult to be
amazing at both of those both of those
so quickly like it took me two years to
be really good at just delivery
um so i think when i speak to the
majority of people even if they're
leaving 360. they're just like oh i'm on
a rubbish desk i haven't really been
trained on the bd side i haven't really
been trained on the candidate side it's
spreading them too thin whereas when
you're on
just that 180 side you are an expert in
what you're doing and one it's going to
make people trust you more because
they've had that experience because you
are so good at what you're doing from
learning it doesn't mean you're going to
do 180 forever i mean i do 180 and i
manage a team whereas
like if i did i just don't
i think it's too much too soon to throw
people into that 360 and i think that is
why there's such a high turnover in
recruitment because that
it's casting people
too wide whereas i'm now an expert at
placing str's in well placing candidates
into software companies and that gives
you confidence and that gives me that
confidence whereas
i know that if i'd been asked to do the
whole thing from the start i wouldn't be
good at any of them
well look i had a mega year last year
excited to see you where you now can't
believe we're in july
it's exciting to see where you end up in
another
year's time
but uh kudos to you obviously turning it
around i think obviously you could have
gone in that environment where it's just
you free covered and 100 percent
crumbled yeah and like not come out the
other side you've obviously grown
obviously you recently just um obviously
secured your first property
so happy days like congratulations to
you and yeah thank you so much for
coming on the podcast thank you for
having me i've loved it
thank you so much for listening to the
episode i hope you enjoyed it and got
value from the conversation if you did
enjoy it please don't forget to like
share and subscribe and we'll see you in
the next episode